Joe Biden sizing up the Republican field
and taking a shot at his potential
Rivals as more heavyweights get into the
race let's see if he's been able to keep
up with it
I haven't been able to keep up with it
it's moving so quickly and uh you know
I'm not being facetious I'm being very
serious I haven't focused on it that
much it seems got a lot of competent
candidates who are trying to get the
nomination so we'll see
unfortunately Slow Joe seems to have
forgotten that he's a candidate his
campaign is over a month old already but
he's held no events instead Biden is
going to sit back and let all his
campaign surrogates do the heavy lifting
one summing up the strategy this way
quote I think you'll see a real team
effort to support the president and to
be able to convey his message out into
the world so everything doesn't rely on
him alone well Joe lies low Roddy D is
on the go DeSantis will be holding his
first campaign event in Iowa after
vowing to destroy leftism
if I'm the nominee I will beat Biden and
I will serve two terms and I will be
able to destroy leftism in this country
and leave woke ideology on the Dustbin
of History I think there's a reason why
the Legacy Media is attacking me more
than they're attacking anybody else
because I think they realize that if I'm
successful in winning the Republican
nomination we're going to bring it home
in the general election all right it's
not geraldo's boat back there all right
I'm going to call for this thought
because I love it because it has two
people in it one named jolly and the
other name joy and they're both
miserable
you know what I am woke and I'm proud of
it okay Londa Sanchez tonight a very
dark figure on the political landscape
far more dangerous than Donald Trump so
there you go as predicted uh Dana We Now
find out that somebody is worse than
Trump
DeSantis yes yes and then if somebody
else were to get a little bit of a leg
up imagine they'll say that Tim Scott is
worse than Hitler I mean it doesn't
matter who is going to be the
Republicans know that and I think that
Republican voters have tuned that out so
it's not really working I do think it's
interesting to see this week it's a
little bit of a table setting for
Republican politics because both Ron
DeSantis and Trump will be on the trail
this week in Iowa and uh I think that
that shows that President Trump knows
it's not just going to be a coronation
for the nomination and Ronda Santos
people will be able to see okay so is he
able to throw a punch and land a punch
and how would he get up off the mat when
he's attacked
um I do wonder about Ron DeSantis today
he came out with a thing really going
and find to be against the debt deal but
instead of taking it to Joe Biden he
took it to the Republicans like further
dividing them so I don't know if that's
a great idea on Biden I thought it was
interesting that their team thought that
they could go to NBC News and plant this
long story about how they're going to
use celebrity and Tick-Tock influencers
in order to win a presidential election
I imagine that they believe that if
Trump is the nominee that they can just
do a replay of 2020. but I think voters
were a little bit more forgiving about
him being in the basement because of
covid right like they could understand
that that is no longer the case if the
president himself said kovit is over but
they still plan not to have him out on
the trail wow you know Jesse uh if you
elect me I will destroy leftism that's a
pretty good line how do you feel about
that that's a bold lawn and I like it
and you say whatever you can to get over
the Finish Line I think he would just
rip the stitches off Joe Biden in
general but then the FBI would probably
destroy him along with the CIA I'm sure
the Pentagon probably has a picture of
him stacking up Iraqi bodies in a
Baghdad prison cell or something like
that either that or they'll probably tap
his phones
it worked in 2016. you don't think
they're going to play dirty with Rhonda
santis they are going to get Disney
they're going to get BlackRock and
they're going to get these defense
contractors and they're going to burn
this man to the ground doesn't matter
who the nominee is they are going to
torch the sob and now
we can nominee
can be not as bad as Trump think about
if Trump is a racist Trader slash rapist
slash Rebel can you have the Lev come
out and say well he's not as bad as
Trump I mean you can't say well actually
that sounds pretty good he's not as bad
it has to be absolutely worse I'm so
angry at the Press right now you have
Joe Biden who hides for a year he comes
out and talks to you without any notes
and your first question is what do you
think of the Republicans yeah you don't
ask why'd your family nine members of
them take 11 million dollars in bribes
you know why is the majority of the
country think you're not mentally sharp
enough to be president why does
two-thirds of the country think that
your re-election is going to be a
disaster why won't you debate RFK Jr
none of that gets asked and so that's
how this guy is going to survive
permission to make an analogy all right
then you stopped Greg I've been off for
a couple days
this is like this is like a football
game when one quarterback you're not
allowed to sack
this is like the other quarterback
you're allowed the kneecap you're
allowed the helmet to helmet I gouge in
the scrub one guy you can't even breathe
on so Joe Biden's gonna get out there
and he's going to be like I'm going to
lock up Trump and hide I'm going to
arrest my opponent and I'm going to stay
in Delaware and no one's allowed to ask
me any questions except Dylan that's the
strategy who's now straight he is I
believe listen I I saw that we're doing
a whole hour special on it tonight he's
straight I don't know judge I can drink
Bud Light again yeah yeah oh boy you
know the the thing about the left is
they say you know the right is going to
take us back a hundred years they're
going to take us back wait a minute
you're the people talking about white
supremacy and reparations and tearing
down history and taking down statues and
you think the right is going to take you
back a hundred years and first of all
and secondly I should say is this this
whole Reliance on surrogates it feeds
right into the idea that Joe Biden
doesn't have the mental acuity or the
physical capacity to be a candidate and
that's their admission that it takes a
village to use a woman a famous woman's
last line it takes a village and finally
uh this whole idea that you know they're
gonna they're gonna boost Kamala which
is part of their strategy they literally
had Kamala Harris sitting between Joe
Biden and Kevin McCarthy and during the
debt uh ceiling discussions have you
heard the woman say anything about the
debt ceiling is it all just pictures and
smoke and mirrors that's all it is they
can and I just saw Jim Comey on another
station and he's like yeah today he was
out again talking about how the
Republicans are going to take us back
down and I'm thinking to myself you're
the fool who lied to Congress you put an
unverified uh affidavit in front of a
fisa judge and they violated the Fourth
Amendment rights of an American citizen
despite a president like they do in a
third world tree and you have the nerve
to show your face and say the
Republicans are the ones who were a
threat to democracy it is stunning
what's going on
geralda thanks for inviting me this
weekend absolutely yeah we had two or
three burgers for you well you know what
I had other plans pretty social guy
um
so I mean I really don't care what
question I ask you go ahead and answer
anything you want so I think the setup
and I think a lot of what you're saying
I think is is largely right I think the
setup is the Sunny Lane that is being
occupied by Tim Scott right now in the
lane that that frankly is not
um I think that listening to Ron
DeSantis you know I expect bigger from
him from in terms of the ideas saying
you want to do you're going to defeat
leftism look I I get it that may be a
nice thing to say to our Republican
County meeting somewhere in Florida but
the country is faced with real
challenges your point then about the
criticism around the debt ceiling it'd
be different if he said look I want to
cut this this and that and I think we
ought to raise taxes or lower tax he
just criticizes I think politics should
have just criticized Biden well whatever
you you think you should but but I'm
saying is he had no ideas if the only
ideas in politics today on either side
is if Democrats to say the Republicans
think they're terrible they're going to
turn us back 100 years and for
Republicans to say Democrats are going
to do the same thing the people who lose
the most are the people I sat on this
show a few days ago Tyrus had one of the
great lines on one of the shows earlier
last week about the debt selling as you
talked about how silly and immature some
in Washington have were behaving he said
the real losers are going to be people
if all we tell people in campaigns not
crime not border not how we compete and
be cut and de-risk from China but
leftism and the Republicans wanted to
this this is the last thing we need as
we find ourselves almost a quartered
away through the 21st century if this is
all our politics is then we're not going
to solve the crime issue we're not going
to deal with the debt selling issue
we're not going to deal with the
underlying factors and we're not going
to find ways to compete more with China
and decouple from them these are the
issues that I believe are most important
I hope that both sides get to them I
think America needs a dose of Herald 4
Junior 2024 what am I saying
you're starting to feel like you're the
only one who's going to get this thing
done and you know I'm beginning to
believe that we could file the paperwork
tomorrow yeah yeah and we're not
partisan all I do know is watch prime
time I watch 9 A.M and I watch 11 p.m so
if I could find ways to do that do
something else hi winner Brian Kilmeade
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now